je me suis comme moi ne fait jamais
brousmiche et vous voilà voilà petit pot
qui pensent à gré à bongo comme vous
l'aurez compris d'après ce move
extraordinaire aujourd'hui c'est une
foire aux questions alors on y va je
vous ai comme d'habitude demandé sur
twitter de me poser toutes vos questions
avec le hashtag squeeze question alors à
quand une vidéo on essaye d objets
étranges 4 écoute c'est marrant tu dis
ça parce qu'il ya pas longtemps j'ai
parlé à ma femme et moi je leur ai dit
les gars j'ai hâte qu'on ouvre de
nouveau des objets what the fuck ce à
quoi ils m'ont répondu nous aussi à
condition qu'on ne met pas le feu at-on
studio parce qu'on est quand même papa
nous contrairement à toi je me suis donc
énorme étant donné que je suis papa d'un
merveilleux chien qui a fraîchement eu
un an je vois les anniversaires natsu il
est pas là aujourd'hui je suis dégoûté
bref je divague j'aimerais en tournée
une rapidement à la rentrée pour être
franc avec vous mais je vais pas au
japon cet été donc je trouve ça moyen
d'acheter des objets du dom quichotte
sans aller au japon mais peut-être qu'à
d'autres sites qui vendent les mêmes
trucs et ou en tout cas si vous vous
avez la chance d'aller au japon bat qui
fait bien fait un petit saut dom
quichotte vous allez trouver des objets
vraiment marrant et incongrue vous allez
rennes en faire mais c'est pas grave
à quand une nouvelle alors déjà beaucoup
trop de questions qui commencent par à
caen vraiment les gens attendent trop de
choses de moi ça va pas du tout à quand
une nouvelle vidéo avec big flo au liban
quand ils sortiront un nouvel album
brand content de revoir ces images
bah franchement elle ne procure un
sentiment positif parce qu'elle me
rappelle d'où je viens et dans la vie
c'est important de ne pas oublier d'où
l'on vient mais à la fois de savoir où
on va mais aussi de comprendre d'où ça
vient
non surtout c'était un très bon souvenir
parce que j'étais avec mon meilleur pote
quand j'ai fait cette vidéo est elle en
a gardé un souvenir mémorable
contrairement au parquet qui lui étaient
pleins duff théorie puisque en gros tu
mettais on s'éclatait des eaux sur la
tête dans toutes les vidéos mais ouest
soit pas ouais est ce que tu es au
courant de le paix de maxence nom
qu'elle paie quand combien tu dépenses
est sûre fort night en euros
je sais pas et je ne veux pas savoir 500
euros alors j'ai la chance grâce à vous
de recevoir tous les jeux presque
gratuitement les éditeurs me les envoie
du coup me fait économiser beaucoup
d'argent au lieu de deux piécettes un
bon escient le mettre de côté le donne à
ma maman j'en sais rien bah je lance
fort knight et je le mets dans
fahrenheit donc c'est horrible la
solution au problème ces sommes c'est
que je dois travailler sur moi même et
demande à epic games de m'offrir les
skins comme ça je mettrai l'argent dans
un autre jeu mais je le garderai
toujours pas qu'est ce que tu aimes le
plus dans ton métier actuel faire ce que
je veux faire vraiment ce que je veux et
j'ai pu essayer de 30 mètres des 30
mètres waouh
j'ai vraiment besoin de vacances que je
préfère c'est transmettre des choses
positives
peu importe que c'est à vous c'est ça
que j'aime bien c'est essayer
d'apprendre des trucs aux gens si je
peux ou les divertir mais toujours dans
le positif et pas dans le négatif
et contrairement à avant je fais
beaucoup plus attention à ce que je dis
en vidéo parce que des faces ou
l'excitation sous le délire avec les
potes on peut faire des blagues ou des
trucs qui parce qu'on entre potes mais
qui passe pas quand on a regardé par des
inconnus qu'on peut transmettre des
trucs tellement incroyable tellement
forts qui peuvent tellement faire du
bien aux gens qu'il faut en avoir
conscience et il faut se pencher vers ça
en fait du bonheur un moment
divertissant un souffle du nez un gros
sourire j'en sais rien mais c'est ça que
j'aime bien ça que je préfère est aussi
le fait de pas avoir de patron une
expérience traumatisante dans ta vie ou
simplement une expérience qui t'a fait
te remettre en question il n'ya pas
longtemps j'ai vécu un truc qui m'a fait
me remettre en question je suis allé à
une soirée d'une marque lou je voulais
pas y aller mais bref pour divers
raisons je suis allé au final et j'ai
absolument tester tout ce qui m'entoure
est vraiment tout le monde se filmer
tout le monde était sur son 31
c'était le concours du kiel plus beau et
qui pèse le plus et en fait ça peut
paraître con mais ça m'a traumatisée
attention gros traumatisme a droit à la
vie de bateaux privilégié c'est génial
mais je veux dire il ya des gens qui
cherchent toutes leurs vies à aller à ce
genre d'événement mais vraiment c'est
nul je sortir avec mes potes une aprem
aller au parc avec natsu c'est tellement
trop bien tellement la meilleure chose
que je peux faire en fait en fait des
fois les toutes les plus simples que tu
as ou menée sur les meilleures choses
que tu peux faire froid que ma place est
vraiment dans un parc avec mon chien
ramasser c'est quelqu'un c'est là où je
me sens bien et vivent à quand un copain
ou une copine
pour natsu [ __ ] mais j'ai tellement
envie non réellement j'ai vraiment envie
qu'ils connaissent l'amour d'ailleurs je
le soupçonne d'être homosexuel pour être
franc avec vous puisque il a
régulièrement envie de faire l'amour à
son meilleur ami
ce qui me dérange absolument pas mais je
suis triste parce que du coup ils
pourront pas faire de petits et des
petits natsu ce serait rigolo comme
accor la grosse vidéo du 10 millions
d'abonnés
voir je vais expliquer un peu la vidéo
des millions du coût mais en gros je
vais faire une surprise à plusieurs
personnes à travers le monde en allant
toquer chez eux sans qu'ils s'y attendre
vraiment et en les emmenant faire des
activités cool en échangeant un moment
avec eux vraiment en one to one comme on
dit parce que c'est ces moments là je
préfère c'est les moments où je peux
parler à une personne sans tout un
bordel au tour juste lui et moi je peux
découvrir ce qu'il fait dans la vie ce
qu'il aime qui il est en fait je crois
que je vais vivre un l'un des trucs les
plus forts de toute ma vie en fait et
puis voilà j'ai trop hâte et ça sortira
je pense qu'il est probablement de plein
de gens m'ont posé la question ça
sortira en septembre je sais pas encore
la date mais je vous la donnerais dans
une future vidéo voilà je ferai une
petite annonce pour ça mais voilà en
tout cas on va commencer par la tournée
cette vidéo avec un million d'abonnés de
retard mais c'est vous aussi vous allez
trop vite vous abonner tous aura tune
d'autres grands projets et ben du coup
je viens de répondre à cette question
vous a vu j'ai bien géré mon dérouler
une vidéo en tout cas c'est chouette je
suis vraiment talentueux aujourd'hui non
en vrai il ya un autre gros projet qui
arrivera plus tard dans l'année j'en
avais déjà parlé dans une vidéo avec
jules fouetter aux flashbacks on faisait
une réunion pour un gros projet qui
sortira vers septembre octobre
cela peut rien vous dire là dessus pour
le moment mais ça va vraiment changer de
tout ce que j'ai pu faire comme gros
projet j'ai pas spécialement le talent
je pense pour faire un court métrage
mais là j'ai trouvé un truc qui entre
deux choses et qui est déjà à gratter un
peu le brief de la vidéo des 10 millions
alors cela vous allez attendre à roger
appris que ça n'allait pas fort en ce
moment avec maxence que pourrait-il
faire pour te reconquérir bronche pas où
vous taste info meiway depuis depuis peu
là ça va ça va pas fort entre nous tête
je vais l'appeler pour en parler de vive
voix tu vois
[Musique]
alors ouais il ya un mec sur twitter y'a
un mec sur twitter cas qui a compris que
ça allait plus trop entre nous en fait
explique je trouve une petite foire aux
questions il ya un mec qui dit j'ai vu
que ça allait plutôt avec maxence est ce
que c'est lié à l'éloignement du au
concert et où je vais un peu mal le fait
que tu sois plus trop là à cause de ta
tournée avec vaisseau et puis voilà
j'aimerai juste peut-être un peu plus de
sms tu vois que tu m'envoies est comme
ça peut-être c'est réglé quoi
[Musique]
max un jeune acteur est ce que tu as
prévu de faire un bébé avec une petit
buzz et fonder une famille et que
pense-t-il de killian mba paies ta
question tombe à point j'avais prévu de
faire un bébé de fonder une famille avec
kylie ann bape est en fait un conte
vidéo pour sensibiliser contre l'abandon
en période de vacances d'été et au
quotidien aussi mais en ce moment c'est
important chaque chien l'a pas bon
joueur très très juste
oh non pas encore ceux de twitter qui va
très bien avec ton propos d'ailleurs ben
écoute profitons de cette afin qu
peut-être pour sensibiliser les gens
comme vous le savez peut-être qu'il ya
énormément de gens qui abandonnent leurs
animaux à la proche des grandes vacances
et du coup ils préfèrent oublier les
responsabilités qu'ils ont accepté de
prendre en adoptant cet animal en
acceptant de recevoir son amour et les
[ __ ] à la rue les lâcher au bord de la
route les lâchers attaché à un poteau
les envoyer au dessus des grilles de spa
bref plein de trucs affreux sachiez pour
ceux qui veulent partir en vacances et
convoquant moyens de s'occuper de leurs
animaux bas vous avez fait le choix de
prendre un animal vous avez donc fait le
choix de faire ce qu'on appelle des
concessions à savoir ah bah non il ya
mon image pas partir en vacances dont je
les abandonne pour partir banon a acquis
non tu pars pas et tu t'occupes de ton
animal à la place c'est comme ça que ça
marche
ou alors tu demandes un ami de garder tu
t'arranges pour partir en vacances à des
dates différentes de tes amis ou alors
tu le mets dans un hôtel pour chats ou
chiens ça existe bref tu trouve des
solutions et une arbre donnes pas ton
animal comme un gros fils de tuer
énormément évolué sur youtube depuis tes
débuts et beaucoup de monde le dit alors
comment s'annonce la suite sur youtube
est-ce que tu va peu à peu quitté le jeu
encore plus que maintenant je sais
panneaux en fait il ya plein de gens qui
m'ont dit ah tu quittes le gaming terek
définitivement banon déjà parce que
quand je vais jouer ça va être surtout
sur twitch fait pas beaucoup de live
actuellement mais j'ai un gros programme
prévu pour la rentrée avec des lives
ailleurs fixé tout mais je vous en
parlerai au
nu donc du coup je vais concentrer le
gaming sur twitter et je vais concentrer
le reste sur youtube même s'ils auraient
encore des vidéos gaming sur youtube
mais en fait je fais ce que j'aime est
actuellement j'adore raconter des
histoires parler de sujets qui me font
marrer de faire des vidéos avec les
potes sur des trucs divers et variés
faire des concepts hors du studio faire
des musiques du coup en fait je suis
vraiment mais en vie actuellement mais
jeux vidéo font un peu moins partie de
mes envies que le reste par rapport à
avant et c'est bien ça montre que
j'arrive à me renouveler à m'amuser
enfin d'autres trucs c'est chouette mais
effectivement je pense y aura toujours
un peu moins de gaming sur ma chaîne que
par rapport à 2014 ou 2015 nous lie avec
eux ça mais bon à côté de ça il ya du
switch enfin il y aura du switch à la
rentrée par rapport à un 2014 2015 dont
vous aurez quand même votre petite dose
de jeux vidéo et tu es en train de
passer actuellement un agréable moment
wasquehal mer fermée de l'asie
occidentale est bordée par la jordanie
est par israël
la mer morte
oui oui on
[Musique]
quoi est ce que tu penses un jour faire
une vidéo court métrage sur tout et
perso d'avant juste pour le soutenir
il négocie juste le souvenir bah bah
ouais bah comme un gars lui dit si bien
en dessous ça serait cool en effet mais
je pense que pour lui c'est du passé en
fait ouais c'est vraiment du passé c'est
vraiment des trucs que j'ai fait à une
époque je dois dire votre faq mais même
les trucs que je fait récemment les
trade les théories du complot et tout
j'espère que dans un ou deux ans même
avant ça se trouve je ferai autre chose
que ça en fait pour continuer à prendre
autant de plaisir dans ce que je fais et
que vous vous continuez à adhérer aux
trucs en fait parce que justement ça
avance et évoluent a changé et c'est
plaisant alors où là alors là on a vu
une question en une tu devras c'est la
nuit non basse et je me rends murray
j'aimerai toujours dormir plus que ce
que je dors tu mange correctement le
matin alors maintenant je mange pas le
matin parce que j'ai pas faim mais
récemment je me vois là je me mets des
petits spécial car dans du lait d'amande
voilà est-ce que c'est bien ou pas je
sais pas mais ça me fait du bien moi tu
bois suffisamment d'eau alors je me suis
mis à boire comme ado il n'y a pas très
longtemps mais ya pas très longtemps je
me suis bien moi rebond en boire moins
qu'ils attaquent
c'est la pire réponse mon prince mérite
d'être en bonne santé
bah je manque un peu d'eau voilà donc
éventuellement si tu veux me livrer des
fois un ou deux packs d'eau tu peux y a
pas de souci comment t'es venue l'idée
de faire des vidéos sur des threads
crépy j'adore ce concept continue à nous
se pâment avec ça moi j'adore aussi ce
concept j'adore raconter des histoires
en ce moment et j'ai toujours aimé
raconter des histoires en fait mais
j'avais pas grand chose à raconter à
part dans les vidéos anecdotes jargon
plein de trucs qui me sont arrivées mais
du coup les threads et des histoires que
j'ai mais j'adore les remanier un peu à
ma sauce et vous raconter d'une manière
qui de blaye et puis clément ensuite le
montage fait un travail formidable
d'illustration donc ça donne un format
assez cool je trouve aux gars vous avez
été très nombreux à me dire que ça vous
plaît de ouvre donc je suis hyper
content j'espère continuer ce format
pendant encore un petit moment en
essayant de patron en abuser non plus en
vrai mais je crois que l'idée m'était
venue avec le fameux ce raid sur le
message vocal que j'avais trouvé
exceptionnel
et puis je me suis dit [ __ ] mais en
fait je pourrais raconter aux gens et
leur faire vivre aussi le truc quoi ça
peut être cool alors gérer l'inventaire
mon avis je suis pas du tout le premier
à faire ça vraiment mais en tout cas
j'ai eu l'idée moi même même si d'autres
gens l'avaient fait avant je m'étais dis
moi même [ __ ] j'ai envie de raconter
ce truc quoi ça me fait plaisir puis moi
ça vaut aussi est-ce que de temps à
autres tu regrettes d'être célèbre tu
aimerais des fois ne pas être reconnu
c'est un supplice les gens viennent
viennent me voir comme ça ils font mecs
j'adore ce que tu fais c'est trop cool
continuer je les regarde je fais mec tu
peux pas me dire ça c'est abusé et abuse
ouf non en vrai et les 95% du temps
c'est vraiment chouette surtout
maintenant en fait c'est beaucoup de
gens très posé très mature qui veulent
pas m'embêter parce qu'ils savent que
c'est la vie privée en dehors des vidéos
mais qu'ils veulent quand même me dire
un tout petit monde parce que ça leur
fait plaisir de me le dire est qu'ils
ont l'occasion de le faire il ya juste
quelques fois où effectivement pas des
hordes de de 14 personnes qui arrivent
en gueulant qui sont batteleku il faut
que ce soit seul ou accompagné ça change
rien là j'avoue c'est un moment un peu
plus délicat mais est ce que je peux
leur en vouloir d'être contents de me
voir en vrai alors que c'est attendait
pas banon via l'effet de groupe moi
j'avoue si je vois un mec je ne vais pas
le voir en vrai chèque mes potes je vais
je vais devenir aouf en vrai nom il ya
vraiment très peu de désavantage le seul
vrai des avantages que ja c'est pas ça
du tout c'est quand un livreur à ton
numéro et on profite un peu derrière ça
c'est chiant tu penses prendre un
deuxième chien
j'y pense pas et justement de prendre en
compte ce que ça implique d'avoir un
animal et avoir un deuxième chien c'est
pas comme un deuxième chat ou juste eu
mes deuxièmes litière tumulte deuxième
gamelle et bats les couilles l'amex et
sortir avec de l'ess avoir l'oeil sur
deux chiens quand tu l'aimés sans laisse
dans le par enfin je trouve que c'est
une grosse grosse implication donc oui
je pense prendre un deuxième chien mais
non pas maintenant raconte une anecdote
gênante quand tu as rencontré un abonné
c'est horrible j'aime pas faire ça mais
en gros j'étais en j'ai dit j'aime pas
faire ça puis je suis suivie de passer à
l'étape où je raconte l'anecdote c'est
horrible je descendais d'un train en
suisse pour aller prendre à manger
c'était en revenant du ski en revenant
de crans montana on était parti avec les
potes là-bas c'était cool et en revenant
on avait un changement à faire en fait
on était encore en suisse pendant
changement on décide d'aller prendre un
truc à un fast food et au fast-food ya
un mec qui me reconnaît qui est très
insistants bas je parle avec lui le
temps chez mado puis en partant ims une
image à côté de moi et continue de me
parler et je lui dis mec j'ai mon train
dans cinq minutes
désolé je dois accéléré fait ok pas de
souci est au plus bas à marcher plus
vite et a toujours continué à côté de
moi de me parler jusque là rien de
gênant sauf qu'en fait il me disait
qu'il était rappeur qui voulait faire un
album de rap et qui voulait faire un
feat avec moi qui veut faire un feat
avec squeeze mais quelle sorte de l'apr
études j'arrive devant mon wagon il est
il est là quoi sert le mec m'a suivi
vraiment c'était loin le fast food
ensuite je rentre dans le wagon et il va
pour rentrer et là les aujourd'hui mais
que enfin que kalou quoi tranquille et
il était hyper insistant et ça m'avait
vraiment brusquer mais bon il n'était
pas méchant dans le fond il n'est pas du
tout méchant mais en fait il n'était pas
hyper net donc j'avais peur qu'il fasse
on fait un fit que je réponde bah non en
fait je fais pas trop
et au petit plant comme ça un petit coup
de couteau comme ça j'extrapole mais on
n'était pas loin de ça vraiment quand
est-ce que tu refera un cache-cache
géant en fin d'année très bonne question
j'ai trop hâte on va refaire un
cache-cache géant vert fin novembre
mi-décembre un truc comme ça
la première vidéo a extrêmement bien
marché j'ai reçues même beaucoup de
messages de gens du sud viennent pour me
dire mec c'était trop bien cette vidéo
des messages de vous j'en parle même pas
il ya eu énormément de gênes de
commentaire voilà vous avez adoré la
vidéo et vous m'avez montré et vous
l'avez surtout montré à honor qui
sponsorisait la vidéo parce que faire un
cache-cache de cette manière ça coûte de
l'argent mexes pas pour rien qu'on peut
pas le faire en vidéo du coup ils ont
dit oui pour un deuxième épisode lors de
la sortie du prochain au nord alors
voila merci à vous pour vous les avez
couvertes us à gaza j'ai trop hâte
m'engage une cachette un ça va être trop
bien les amis c'est la fin de cette
foire aux questions j'ai répondu à
beaucoup de trucs a eu beaucoup de
premier degré bas au moins vous aurez
appris pas mal de choses c'est vraiment
ces vidéos là où je me lâche pour vous
dire plein de trucs que je ressens ce
que je pense c'est juste un peu moins
drôle que les autres mais bon c'est ça
reste quand même divertissant
j'espère bref j'ai encore quelques trucs
à vous dire mais je ferai une vidéo pour
l'occasion une vidéo bonus avant de
partir en vacances pour vous dire tout
ça il ya plein d'autres choses que tout
n'est pas encore exactement après je
veux pas dire de bêtises mais bon bref
il ya plein de trucs cool qui vont
arriver à la rentrée plein de trucs
remotiver qui me font kiffer qui font
que je continue à faire ce que je fais
du moins que je continue à le faire avec
autant de plaisir
j'espère qu'aux vacances se passe très
très bien moi elles vont bien se passer
sera plus en août merci pour tout je
vous aime puis je vous dire maintenant
une prochaine vidéo plus amusante mais
avec un coeur un peu moins ouverts allez
vas-y à la maison j'ai pu faire ça à
bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo
[Musique]